finally
playing a video game everybody hooray
detroit become human the dumbest title
ever i can never remember
it like beyond two souls
what the hell is that detroit become
human come up with a normal title please
i spent the last five minutes just being
like what was the name of the game again
hello oh god welcome to the detroit
experience
ugh i'm an android and i'll be your
hostess oh this is a
before we begin let's make some
adjustments to optimize your experience
these language settings were detected on
your console
are they correct oh my god she's
breaking the fourth wall
oh that's awesome i'll do medium
i'm a medium kind of guy man
it's weird it's weird when you see uh
you know what i won't go there please
adjust your screen settings
okay they're fine they're fine trust me
they're fine
okay just thank you yeah welcome select
your profile
what do you want what profile x uh i
want immersive gameplay
with advanced controls uh well if you
pick
casual you shouldn't even be playing
here we go
when this sign is displayed please do
not turn off your console
well you can't tell me what to do we are
now ready to begin detroit
thank you remember this is not just a
story
this is our future
sure sure buddy anyway i'm really
excited to play this game
i love heavy rain it's one of my
favorite games beyond two souls you know
it was entertaining but no it wasn't
good so that's why i was kind of
hesitant when this came out i didn't
really want to check it out right away
until reviews came in and then
i just got off the hype train and
everyone had already played it so i
thought maybe i shouldn't play it but
then i realized that is actually really
cool
i i want to play it i genuinely want to
play it so here we are
i hope you guys enjoy me on this uh
journey it's always fun to do let's
plays
if it's a good game and i'm told this is
good
and i'm walking everybody
you hear stuff in the background hey let
me take this
for those of you who are not familiar
with these type of games they're always
very
story oriented uh
leaving you with random options in front
of you
heavy rain was so revolutionary in the
genre i don't care about your girl
let me go off on a monologue wait
you're sending an android all right
ma'am you need to go
you can't do that you why aren't you
sending a real person
hey i am a real person thank you
all right all right captain ally
uh consult your objectives all right
what do we got fine
all right looks like he's that way give
a [ __ ]
just get the order what's going on here
bro android here oh oh oh
hello captain allen my name is connor
i'm the android sent by cyberlife
it's firing at everything that moves i
already shot down
um i don't know
what's the it's name i haven't got a
clue
does it matter i need information to
determine the best approach
um how is the action you know if it's
been behaving strangely before this
i don't know what's happening so it's
kind of hard to determine listen
saving that kid is all that matters so i
was a hostage this [ __ ] android now
i'll take care of it oh i see what's
happening
probability of success every second
counts what
understand what happened okay save
hostage at all costs
i'll save the hostage understand what
happens
sorry my objective is what
oh it's all of these things i thought i
could pick
units this is really interesting
all right analyzed was trying to
all right what happened to you the first
officer that responded
okay we gotta find clues okay that's
cool all right what have we got
collecting data p.o deckard anthony
yeah i want no one will care about
anyone named anthony
what a loser lead that scytheman i'm
joking
stop crying only one shot okay all right
need one more look i found it guys i
must be some sort of detective
all right right heart ventricle okay all
right that's
let's deconstruct this everyone use
l to re okay so we can see what happened
oh that's cool
shot through the heart in your jewels
blame
darling you give love
a bad name
cop shot the deviant rewind to search
for a new clue
and there was a hostage
giving some moral support got it okay
and then there must be another clue here
somewhere let's see here
there it is i am g honestly i'm a genius
you're watching a genius let's play here
everyone you're welcome we found it
we found the gun it's under the table
no one thanks to hyper
technology we managed to found the
unfound weapon
it's been here for years no one could
ever possibly have found it without me
well i guess i can't delete fingerprint
prints if i'm an android so
i'll just go ahead and join stir that
one
that was close guys don't worry youtube
bots aren't on us
what is that blue blood
yes i love this so far
okay so our probability of success
increases the more
uh information
dude you just stay back all right we
found the house
[Music]
why does he kind of strangely look like
me
what's your name my name is connor i
mean my name is what about you
what is your name daniel that's the name
they gave me
stay back oh so i skipped two things
nah fam
i'm playing this game wrong i'll go back
i don't and
yeah okay since i'm replaying this i
might as well
say what i wanted to say which is uh
i love these type of games
especially heavy rain the reason why i
have rain is one of my favorite games is
because you truly felt like
you impacted the story with your
decisions there's so many different
endings in that game
and if you messed up the goal was to
save your son right and if you messed up
you could actually
it's such a dark ending and if you make
it the game continues
i don't know i thought it was brilliant
and then beyond two souls came
out and the whole game basically just
plays itself i think it's an insult to
video games almost in retrospect
uh but what i'm seeing so far is that
this is actually they
they've gone back to the roots
i love these type of games where you
really feel okay we're back
okay we're back i was gonna say i love
these type of games where
uh it really feels like
your decision makes an impact but also
it's hard to play for youtube because oh
my god
because people get so mad if they know
you make the wrong mistake
or the wrong move uh i will tell you i
will try my best to make the right
decisions but
that does not family was about to have
dinner
so we have two more things to do search
the hostage room
and examine the victims now we did that
can i run
probably if we go out like i did and we
fail
uh the story will be different or
they're just giving us bs and the story
will go on no matter what the same way
that's the problem with these games they
a lot of it is just
making you think that you have a choice
i think that's why the telltale games
got so stale
because you play it the first time and
you're like whoa
i really feel like i'm making an impact
on the story and i'm making my own
decisions and then you realize no
it's the same for everyone not a
playstation vr wow missed opportunity
wait it's headphones oh the child didn't
hear
wait this doesn't mean if you if you
love the life you live
you will live a life of what
that's the dumbest thing i ever heard
was she watching are you pie on youtube
i'm swiping on my thing zoella no
wow danielle you don't seem so cool now
conveniently have that video played
i don't buy this this is too hey our
probability
of success has increased all right
uh examine the victims who's the victims
oh here's the big one how you doing
buddy
not so good i don't know why i asked
okay so
oh i we got an eye we got an eye
everyone
are the ends boop
okay same same mean different guy
uh-huh all right along parolee x
who doesn't have one of those what a cry
baby
what an absolute okay i know he's dead
where am i supposed to look what's that
where must be on his face it must be his
hair
oh it was his titty i knew it
yes best let's play
on youtube everyone
okay what did we get he was uh just
sitting chilling
he's holding something all right
interesting very interesting what else
have we got
oh my god the recoil
um a guy just shot him
that's not nice
um what does that mean okay we analyzed
everything
oh he dropped to something you mean the
are you kidding me you could have just
found that without all that
you son of a gun how could you
all right so we still only have 76
70 person
uh what is the flow chart oh
what so we missed some stuff talk to
captain allen
what what
what what no that's
cool
okay so locate the hostage
it's the only thing left
okay there's something in the gun all
right so we know we
well we already found the gun
what else could there be
oh bullets
okay so there is more
the deviant took the father's gun okay
so we know he's armed basically
78 still what the frick i guess there's
still just
some chance
every second counts i gotta hurry
okay [ __ ] are you doing i think we
officially did everything
we have no choice at this point okay
come on 78 those are good eyes
why would you shoot me i dubbed nothing
don't come any closer or i'll jump no no
please
he would never hurt her
hi daniel oh my name is connor oh how do
you know my name
i know a lot of things about you come to
get you out of this
yacht
come on guys you totally ruin it
okay we found him approach slowly okay
all right daniel come i know you're
angry daniel
but you need to trust me and let me help
you i don't want your help
nobody can help me all i wanted for all
this to stop
i i just want all this to stop
then let the girl go daniel you are
uh mine no i don't have a gun
you're lying ah i know you have a gun
damn it
i'm telling you the truth daniel i came
here unarmed
uh emma and you yeah let's do that oh
you and emma were very close
you think she betrayed you but she's
done nothing wrong she lied to me
did you lie emma
but i was wrong she's just like all the
other humans
ah come on daniel you're being a total
party pooper
what's possible cause uh all right we're
going to replace you
and you became upset that's what
happened right
i thought i was part of the family
i thought i mattered is there something
in the pool but i was just their toy
something to throw away when you're done
sympathetic listen i know it's not your
fault
these emotions you're feeling are just
errors in your software
no it's not my fault oh it's going up
we're doing good
i never wanted this thank you i love
them you know
but i was nothing to them just a slave
to being ordered around
yeah you're being a total cry baby
i can't stand that noise anymore
tell that helicopter to get out of here
oh
[Music]
okay except
is under control
[Laughter]
now oh that's
come on last chance i'm your last chance
daniel
if you let it slip they'll kill you let
them
god damn it i have no other choice come
on i'm just trying to push a little bit
i want everyone to leave
and i want a car when i'm outside the
city i'll let her go
no no fam uh
okay you know what you
intimidate yeah what now
is this really what you want you lied to
me hey
hey come on man come on it's up to you
how the story ends
make the right choice daniel
whoa what what
what no
are you no me i didn't want this
no did i you must be no choice
yeah but your choice you're being a
total doofus
oh my god
[Music]
dammit
i am so pissed
[Music]
there you go there you go
okay so there are one two
three four five maybe even six
if i use the gun there was another
option i guess to shoot him
that is so cool that they show you
see this is what i mean now i actually
feel like
uh
i wasted too much time apparently
oh my god this is so cool
can i go back though that's the real
question i don't think i can
okay leave the gun sorry
i thought i could play cool guess not
come on
you're not going to die we're just going
to talk nothing yes
trust me okay
i trust you um
don't make don't shoot me in the face
please yes
that's what you get daniel oh my god
this is mortal kombat scene
okay we did it guys we did it finally it
took a while
he's like you son of a father
i mean you shot me technically
you shot me okay so i don't know what to
tell you
connor gives the fattest dab right now
no
mission success yes
pretty cool seems really promising so
far
what do you guys think smash like
everybody
smash like
wait wait what
did i just play that without saving
no no no no no no
are you kidding me i can't i cannot
okay i gotta pee all right we're back
everybody
yay we're gonna play more
that took me a lot longer than probably
what the video is
all right who's this annoying little
prank i can already tell
you know this is the top of the range
household assistant
it cooks ten thousand different dishes
come on let's go ten
thousand different dishes what is this
elementary school machine sorry tell me
more about this
oh the part that android content is
amazing
this is exactly what we need oh am i one
of the
showcases oh i am aren't i
that's awesome
are they gonna come up uh next to me
this one gives amazing hand jobs
plumbing gardening repairs at night
it switches to surveillance mode
contacts emergency services if there's a
break-in or if it detects smoke
i mean that's pretty awesome over there
the mp800 is slightly more expensive
does anyone know all the fortnite dances
come along
oh really can you do the l dance okay
now that is literally me anytime
anywhere
else oh god don't buy me it's difficult
getting it back in working order
okay it was really messy oh i'm repaired
again the car hit it stupid accident
ah i see anyway it's as good as new now
except that we had to reset it meaning
we had to wipe its memory
i hope you don't mind it'll be fine oh
damn i don't know what's gonna happen
give it a name
my daughter did ax400 boopybot hole
register your name
damn it i'm a lady my name is cara
cara so innocent so sweet
oh my god uh
this is a cover
[Music]
it's a movie soundtrack so i don't know
if david cage still worked on this
is that his name david cage
he's like the first uh
game developer that really try to make
games into movies
you play one of his first games actually
it's the second one
uh what is it called comments helped me
out i forgot
uh and i remember you play it and it
just says play movie and rewind and all
that stuff
that was a fun game actually you guys
remember that did you watch me play that
game
that was a long time ago that was really
fun
it's come a long way since then it's
pretty impressive to see the development
uh
how these games uh improve throughout
[Music]
it seems also like they learned from
the last one which wasn't bad it just
bad ideas
they desperately wanted to be a movie so
bad i think it was the first game that
they
beyond two souls was the first one the
last one that they showed at like a
movie festival can
movie festival or something like that
[Music]
if you guys had an android what would
you do with it
it's kind of weird because like if you
play with vr and you see
uh other enemies or people it's so fun
to just mess around with and i feel like
if
there was an android you do the same
thing okay david cage is still working
on it
of course he is
uh another thing about this game is that
they always just look incredible
and then we get a really ugly shot of a
tree great
just the faces the way they did faces
i remember playing heavy rain uh before
i did youtube
i spent my last bit of money on that
game i bought a playstation 3
and heavy rain and it was such a i had
such a blast
it was at a time where i didn't really
know what i was doing with my life here
let me help you it was such a good
escapism
all right we're playing as this guy now
i don't know why
sorry i love talking about myself what
do you want
i have no objectives retrieve order six
to six at
i have to go to bellini paint shop
okay
so he's he's just sending out his
android to do his errands
this looks so cool classic idiots
we solved racism by adding androids
now you can hate them instead press r2
to use gps
all right
not this way alright this way everybody
hot dogs
all right you're doing a terrible job
for an android
open your eyes
boy
i can't swear just empty senses
let's check it out here for our old
why do you look at me so demon
i know who you are oh really i can see
through
you you are the one by whom the evil
will come
where's the dab option come on who will
destroy detroit
right i forgot we're in detroit he's the
guy on the cover isn't he
we can no longer live without these
slaves
i guess there's a thing there with that
slaves and the black men
maybe they'll play into that i don't
know
okay so where's the stupid paint shop
there it is right there
bellini paint color since 2009
a very good
hello give me your
finest paint please
identification verified oh he's an
android too this should be awkward
here is your order number eight 847 that
will be 63.99
please confirm payment
hey it's the cover everyone of the game
payment confirmed transaction complete
obviously you guys probably heard that
you can put like a chip in
in your hand and then in some places
very few i think you can pay
using the ship
controls are still awkward as ever would
you guys ever
do that consider doing something like
that
you know things that seems crazy now
might be perfectly fine in the future
it's fun paying for stuff so awkward
already like
put in the card put in the pen awkwardly
waiting
anytime i am waiting to pay something
and you wait for the machine right
i'm always considering like do i small
talk or do i just blankly stare at this
machinery
it's my dilemma every single time what
do you guys do please let me know i
genuinely want to know
because it's so awkward right it's like
just too much time not
to talk no the opposite of what i said
and just enough time that you
could talk hey
no one cares i get it why do you hate me
hey guys check it out we got one of
those tin cans here i mean they're
literally everywhere i don't know why
hey
come on does he not know kung fu come on
neo download
some moves
your job stealer
we're gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ] waste it
do it all right
that's enough leave it alone let us
teach this bastard a lesson
hey hey damage it i'm gonna have to find
you
damage it huh you can take your job next
okay
let's go it sounds like you don't even
need a job if you got another guy just
doing everything for you
get androids right and then just make
them do your job and you get a
commission for it
great
all right where am i going oh i got to
get the bus
you know people always get mad at
destructive technology
that leaves people jobless and it's
understandable
but those uh those technologies bring in
more jobs anyway
it's always a cycle that we've always
gone through
it's like with farming back in the day
when they got machinery from farming
oh they get to oh there it come on that
has to be some sort of rosa park thing
they get to ride at their special place
on the bus
well that was pretty pointless
okay wait so
yeah it couldn't have gone different
ways but we could have explored more i
guess
so let's marcos took the bus everybody
interesting oh this reminds me of heavy
rain so much
i you know what maybe you guys are
judging this guy
i'm sure he's a wonderful guy i'm sure
he's gonna take great care of us
i feel really excited about this how can
he afford her though
and bank use r1 to switch camera angle
it's so awkward because you have to move
your movement
stick everyone hello i'm a gamer at the
gamer here you're going on for two weeks
so the place is a mess
not my fault you're washing you cook the
meals and you take care of
god damn it where the [ __ ] the breath
gone swearing
alice stop it alice
oh there you are that's alice you look
after her
homework bath all that crap
got it yes todd get started down here
then you do upstairs
i really hope there's not gonna be any
sexual favors please
hold r2 to scan the environment okay so
right we're gonna clean that
oh thank god game now this is a game all
right
a wham and simulation
i'm joking okay collect the trash
uh kitchen all right what are we what do
we got oh i
just gotta take you don't start by
taking the trash out you did big old
dingus
what do i do now how do i put it down
yeah oh okay okay
yeah yeah i can get that
all right all right clean the counter
where
you nasty boy you nasty you dirty
disgust oh she just threw away the plate
didn't she look at that
why wash the plates when you can dab on
the planes
clean the coffee table
excuse me how about
tv
this guy eats a lot of pizza how does
she fit all those pizza cartons in that
trash bag huh
what is this magical cardboard
plus you can't mix oh okay she has two
bags thank god
i thought the future would be so
irresponsible
uh credit card application form all
right
and the bank it's not doing them
you know if it was me if i had papers
like that i probably would have
oh this is an awkward thing with
controls you're walking this direction
and then all of a sudden you're walking
the opposite and then you start walking
whatever i know you don't care
look at that
oh yeah detroit had all this really bad
neighborhood does
don't they doesn't they do they
i know that movie um we have to be quiet
with a blind guy reminds me this house
reminds me of that one
you're welcome everyone um yes for being
so articulate
what are you looking at the tv dumbass
what do you think
[ __ ] out of here hey you get the app get
the [ __ ] out of here
oh i'm sorry i'll get back to work i
like hockey is that a problem
he has a curved screen wow all right
let's talk to her
all right let's not talk to him jesus
what else do we gotta clean
report to todd
collect the dishes activate the vacuum
option
tasks of course we're gonna
vacuum what do you think this is some
game
nah i care about cleaning
what is he doing what is that sound
what is wrong with you mine's doing some
weird drugs
i've made a good start down here i'll
head upstairs do what you have to do but
stop
bothering me
pee pee bop skippity scoob i love
cleaning
for you oh todd todd is the best
let's go upstairs everyone
can i not clean those up that looks like
can he stop making that sound all right
let's make the bed
event delete the room
so this is why you tuned in for this
let's play to watch someone clean
in a video game it doesn't get better
than this
oh man she's really good at making bed
see this is my dream i hate making the
bed
it's like one of those things i hate the
most if my sheet isn't
perfectly straight i can't sleep so i
have to adjust it all the time
i hate it okay why can't we invent
better sheets
please someone get on that or androids
i mean i'd buy an android
again i always feel so weird about like
i don't like having a cleaning lady or
something like that or cleaning man
if that's the case i just don't like
having other people do
stuff for me but i was like machinery
doing stuff for me
like i don't know why like just
dishwasher in general makes me happy i'm
like this is so great
i don't care about this how do i get out
like if you ever tried a 3d printer it's
always just so fun looking at it work
why would i switch it on
do with my mind and now to sports
first up basketball they really like
yellow in this channel
for the critical match with denver
tonight at the cyber life arena in
detroit
league negotiations are still ongoing
over the possibility of allowing one
android player per squad so there is a
thing about rights between androids and
humans
into more exciting matches i'll be the
first step in making human players
obsolete cyber life has announced its
willingness to participate in the
experiment by providing
one specialized model to every team
androids are already used to train
players and provide
tactical advice that's interesting
another 225 jobs president warren spoke
today at the opening
all right we get it it's a lot of
controversy
we gotta ventilate as well that is
definitely what i wanted to click
man i feel like cleaning in real life
now
i don't know all right what is this
what is this is that me
that must have been okay
todd's room check
we've done that all watch it what i did
i love ta that's so todd i love todd
he's so great oh the toilet is stuck
with todd's poopy
todd is just the best i love todd
uh optional heck yeah we're gonna do the
optional tasks
you kidding me there's options for me to
clean
i just want to tidy up your room a
little i only need two minutes
is that okay alice damn i that's why i'm
so good at cleaning
can't you teach your kids to do this
here themselves
dumb ass
hey alice clean your room
you doofus do i get to do this shake
what is that that unlocked something in
the future
i'm gonna escape right
hello i rights
uh factual friendly diplomatic friends
i'm sure we used to be friends before i
was reset
maybe we can be friends again
um what are you tell me about yourself
what you like to do
where you like to go your favorite foods
that would really help me okay awkward
uh [ __ ] about your mother will
she be home soon
uh oh uh my name is karen who said you
chose my name
cara it's nice how did you choose it
good move here
what did you gave me is it a note
it's a key where does it go
cara is like i love keys i just
love keys ask todd oh
okay so that's like all our memories
[Music]
jacksepticeye i knew he was behind this
after all
that son of a gun
that's the mom is that supposed to be
him
he looked a lot nicer
and she got a little bit of paint on her
head
and then daddy wore a track suit and no
one was happy
about it and then daddy
had a car
hey i lost my arm oh my god
all right let's put it back
i wasn't hit by a car i knew it
i was in one land it was written by an
author in brighton i think someone told
me i don't know if it's true
irib and brighton um there's a lot of
like i don't know if this is true but
there's a lot of uh
people someone built like a tunnel to
the beach and
i don't know if it's true it sounds like
a lie the more i think about it
and like that tunnel was
um inspired alice i don't know
clean bathroom i mean we've done this
much we might as well
and i'm sure you love hearing me talk
about your cheaper rash
so why the heck not there you go shampoo
tidy
then the more i think about it you don't
need an android really you just need a
woman
i'm joking it was a joke
that's a tiny ass mob that's not gonna
oh my god this is so awkward
why is it what he
i have to constantly rub it
okay we've dabbed on all the germs
it's uh time to move on felix okay
my god i'm just trying to make the most
out of the game
i'm truly enjoying it it's really fun
what are you doing i'm playing
yeah what do you think i'm doing
i know what you're thinking
i think your dad's a little life yeah
yeah yes
[ __ ] loser nah stop calling can't get
a job take care of his family
well you can afford him and think i
tried to make things work
but whatever i do when someone comes
along they just [ __ ] it all up
i know what you think of me you hate me
you hate me don't you say it
you hate me
god what am i doing
i love time todd's the best i'm sorry
honey
i'm sorry i'm sorry
you know i love you don't you you know i
love you
all right where's the dab button if
there's not
one moment in this game where there will
be a moment to dab i'm going to be so
disappointed here we go oh look at that
i missed one no
no damn it oh
you're angry all right let's keep
playing we'll do one more we'll do one
more
okay one more one more come on come
on seven a.m
it's not even am waking up in the
morning
cyber life created by mark zuckerberg
whoa what if you were so rich you could
just have an
army of androids that was so epic and
then you can fight them like pokemon
that would be so awesome that is so
awkward
see if you could invent android surely
you could invade pokemons
carl that car is going to be a total
defense
any rich kid is a total doofus
what is this on the wall oh it's one of
those elevators
that is a big thing
hey doofus
where's my doofus wake up carl upstairs
i am upstairs hey
an ancient fossil in your home just like
everyone has
whoa sliding doors
is carl old
carl is old it's got tattoos
good morning carl good morning it's 10
a.m
the weather is partly cloudy 54 degrees
80 humidity with a strong possibility of
afternoon showers
it sounds like a good day to spend in
bed
i did go to pick up the paint that you
ordered oh yes i've forgotten
that is the difference between you and
me right marcus
yeah you don't forget you never forget
anything oh
my god that's what i said
uh so when is the painting meme coming
because i feel like once
once we've done that we can finish the
let's play right
that's the reason show me your arm
please carl
no carl carl
thank you
i just opened my eyes and i'm already
gritty my teeth
humans are such a fragile machine
they break down so quickly all this
effort
to keep them going
hey what happened to your clothes
oh it's nothing just some demonstrators
in the street carl
what a bunch of idiots they think they
can stop progress by roughing up a few
androids
i hope they didn't harm you oh no no
it's the first one that's nice to an
android so far
i'm fine this is so nice i misjudged
carl i feel terrible
uh oh please don't make me do that
have you guys seen the movie her it's a
really good movie about the relationship
between humans and
uh i guess artificial intelligence or ai
or androids i wonder if there will be
like close relationships
in the game like that that is an ugly
cat
what is this
it's got a good atmosphere this game as
well
don't like carl's art just gonna say it
right now anything special on the agenda
today yes there's the opening of your
retrospective
modern art the gallery director left
four messages
asking to confirm your attendance
i haven't decided yet we'll see about it
let me put him on the elevator now okay
what else
or do we get the option to push him just
your usual fan mail
i've already answered
any news from leo that's so cool
well it's so fast i can call him if he's
faster than i
am i want one
okay do i do i push you again or yeah
cool i teleport behind that's always
nice
sliding doors i'm starving whoa what a
cool tv
breakfast is ready bacon and eggs just
the way you like them thank you marcus
you're welcome that's what i said
okay let's oh are we making the
breakfast
i don't know how to make scrambled eggs
i don't like eggs
i already made it thank god
i'm sure the game would have completely
ruined me
okay what's up with the mug it's not
from his kid or something
he has one of those water on the wall
things
that's how you know you're rich
voila thank you marcus
television
if he's unhealthy is it really a good
idea to give him
uh bacon and egg when you do this all
just a question
okay just have some porridge some good
old porridge delicious
makes you poop right after it's great
why don't you find something to do with
it and he doesn't touch that i'm sure
okay eat the fruits carl
in the other games there was like
internal dialogues when you were lost
i guess they don't have it
north pole why russia wants it
we need dominance in space life
where you going with this
what is titan
that's pretty cool television off
damn mankind is so depressing
well i guess nothing's changed in the
future stupidity and violence
5 000 years of civilization just to get
to where we are
wait
what year is it
my man on that whiskey
is that supposed to be no this is fake
ones i thought maybe they would do some
parody ones
like an anime all right let's play the
perfect piano then
melancholic hopeful intimate
well he's feeling a little
let's give him some hope you know
i'm playing this by the way by clicking
the
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
you like this
all right you get to just did you like
it
something has changed in the way you
play
sometimes i think you have more humanity
than most humans
one day i won't be here to take care of
you anymore
you'll have to protect yourself and make
your choices
decide who you are and want to become
this world doesn't like those who are
different marcus
don't let anyone tell you who you should
be
let's go to the studio
all right let's go to the st the meme is
coming
yarns why is those stairs there
is that a giraffe
sure why not why not why not
oh my god can't wait
i'm finally going to see what the
painting is
after all this time
what in the world is happening now let's
see where we left off
remove the sheet
am i supposed to do it
okay well that's prettier
oh we gotta clean this studio while he
this is so cool okay that's terrible
what do i clean then
okay what else
really fun cleaning simulator i i really
really really enjoy it
please please give me more options to
clean
high five i started clean
oh god i don't care give me something to
clean okay here we go
give me something to clean words i never
thought i would say
have i done cleaning for you yet
give me the meme give me the meme give
me the meme give it to me
so verdict marcus
uh i like it yes there is something
about it
[Music]
something i can't quite define
i guess i like it the truth is i have
nothing left to say anymore
each day that goes by brings me closer
to the end
i'm just an old man clinging to his
brushes
carl
but enough about me yes see if you have
any talent
are you telling me you never checked
before i try try painting something
paint but would i painting what anything
you want
give it a try
i'm so curious what it's gonna be
all right
uh find a subject based on
like what i what can i just paint
whatever i want
paint carlos painting that's kind of
weird
uh the desk looks more
uninteresting let's paint the statue oh
we get to do it
squibble squibble
this is how painting works in case you
never painted this is exactly i'm
finally a game why aren't you swiping
that's true to the art of painting
oh my god oh my god that is a perfect
copy of reality
what the painting is not about yesterday
okay we're not there yet improving on it
showing
something you see
carl i don't think i can do that it's
not in my program
go on go try it grab that canvas
let's see let's see
this one's bigger do something for me
close your eyes
close your eyes trust me
oh my god i don't try to imagine
something that doesn't exist
something you've never seen now
concentrate
on how it makes you feel and let your
hand
drift across the canvas
here it is i'm so ready
oh i still get to pick uh
i want to see how he looks at androids
with hope
[Music]
i really hope i wow him
uh
come on
oh my god
oh who's this doo face
hey dad leo
i didn't hear you come in i was in the
neighborhood i thought i'd stop by
it's been a while right
you all right you don't look so good oh
yeah yeah i'm fine
hey listen uh i need some cash dad
again what happened to the money i just
gave you
uh well it just goes you know
yeah you're on it again aren't you no no
no i swear it's not that
ah don't lie to me leo what difference
does it make i just need some cash
that's all
sorry the answer's no
what why you know why
yeah yeah i think i do know why
you'd rather you'd rather take care of
your uh plastic toy here than your own
son
tell me dad what's what's a god that i
don't smarter
more obedient not like me right
but you know what this thing is not your
son
it's a [ __ ] machine leo that's enough
language leo please enough
you don't care about anything except
yourself and your goddamn paintings
you've never loved anyone you never
loved me dad you never loved me
damn it
okay guys that will be it for the first
episode
[Music]
loved it that was so fun hope you guys
enjoyed as well if you did
make it to the end please make sure to
drop a like i would very very very very
much appreciate that
and i'll see you tomorrow with the next
[Music]
one
you